how do I get sin is the Institute of
arson ideas unique festival combining
days full of talks and debates in
philosophy politics arts and science
with evenings full of music and dance
get your tickets for the world's largest
music and philosophy first of all how
that I guess in org so yeah it's pretty
well Andalusian that's a really good
question
I think the answer is no but I can see
why some people think it is an illusion
one reason why people think that is that
they think there's a tension between
determinism the idea that if you kind of
take the universe as it is at any given
moment and run the laws of nature you
can just derive exactly what's going to
happen in the next moment or in the next
thousand years or the next million years
and so now there's they're worried that
here am i I'm raising my hand or talking
or whatever and I can't do anything
about what the distant past was like a
thousand years ago I can't do anything
about what the laws of nature are and so
it looks like it's just not up to me
what I'm doing I'm just kind of like the
conduit through which the laws of nature
sorted past and I'm not really I don't
really have any control over my actions
so that's one thing that people worry
about that's a hard problem to get out
of but I think there are ways of getting
out of it so I'm inclined to think that
there is such a thing as free well
people who think that there isn't such a
thing as free will mostly think that
it's an illusion because they think that
weird that's just something that we take
for granted in our everyday lives that
we can't really escape from you know you
make a decision about what to have for
lunch it really seems to you like it's
up to you what you have for lunch and
it's very hard to rid yourself of that
feeling even if you buy that argument
that says there's no such thing as free
board so that's why they think it's an
illusion I just think that they're wrong
to think that that argument is
persuasive I've got this view about the
turf war between scientists and
philosophers on this issue which it's
not a very original view but it kind of
goes like this so one reason why people
are exercised about freewill is to do
with results coming out of neuroscience
in particular so there are experiments
that you
do that seemed to show that you can
reliably predict the decision that
someone's going to make on the basis of
some spike in electrical activity in
their brain kind of half a second before
they're aware of making a decision now
the view that a lot of neuroscientists
seem to take about that is well that
just shows that our conscious will
doesn't really have any effects on the
world it's like my brain made me do all
of this stuff it's my brain that's
really making the decision and I'm just
kind of become aware of that at some
later point half a second later
so they worried that that again shows
that there's no such thing as free will
there's a lot that one might say about
that experimental setup but I suppose my
basic view and as I say this is not an
original view is just that actually if
you look you're trying to find freewill
you're trying to find some aspects of
human beings that connects in some
interesting way with more responsibility
accountability for our actions which is
why I think the freewill debate is
interesting precisely because it does
connect with those looking at electrical
impulses in the brain that's just the
wrong place to look for something that's
going to connect up in some interesting
way with more responsibility so sure you
can look at a human being as just a kind
of bunch of circuitry muscles and
neurons firing you can look at them as a
sort of object a really close scientific
study but actually if you want to find
things about human beings that are
relevant to their accountability as they
go about their lives you have to kind of
zoom out and look at them as actors on
the social scene you have to think of
them as objects that are worthy of
respect or worthy of sanction or
whatever and you just never you're never
going to find that if you start looking
at them kind of metaphorically through a
microscope you're just looking in the
wrong place right so yeah so the
question is why has this idea that
there's no such thing as free will that
it's just an illusion had such traction
in the last ten years or so that that's
the good question I suppose I mean it's
always been a view that's been out out
there for a long time
I suppose I just want to go about saying
this on camera I think people tend to be
overly impressed with scientific results
like scientific results are great I'm a
big fan of science it's all good
but when scientists sort of stray into
philosophical territory I think they
quite often don't get it right but the
way that they tend to at least get
portrayed in the media is kind of like
having demonstrated quite significant
results that I think obvious
philosophical results that are not
merited by the by the actual scientific
evidence that may be part of the answer
at least is a sort of over deference to
science and scientists so for example
Stephen Hawking and not to know in their
book the grand design or kind of in the
first paragraph they say philosophy is
dead science is all answered all the
questions or will answer all the
questions that traditionally
philosophers were interested in and I
just think that's a really bad mistake
and indeed that book demonstrates what a
mistake it is by wheeling out quite a
lot of philosophy at crucial moments
which is very much not justified by the
sciences just expressing philosophical
views so I wonder whether it's something
to do with deference to science it might
you know I mean it might have something
to do with people sort of not wanting to
take responsibility for their actions
and this is kind of like a a nice quick
and easy way of doing it but I doesn't
really seem to be what's going on most
of the people that say that there's no
such thing as free will when you kind of
press them on whether they really think
nobody's morally responsible for
anything or whether they think that you
know they shouldn't be held to account
when they steal someone's stuff or
whatever tend not to think that so I
don't think it's coming from any sort of
deep kind of social problem where people
just no longer want to take
responsibility for themselves it doesn't
seem to be better I hope it's not that
anyway yes so I guess following on from
the sort of turf wars we're thinking
about things I myself think you know if
we want to understand the nature of
reality and ourselves and
our relationships with other people and
the world at large that's a big
intellectual endeavor that is one that
one should spirit in approached in the
spirit of collaboration right
scientists have something to contribute
to that philosophers have something to
contribute to it you know sociologists
economists historians lots of people
have things to contribute to that so I
think it's a really great idea to bring
people together and try and foster that
kind of communication and so it's it's
difficult it's very difficult when you
read someone like Hawken Hawking or
various other kind of scientists who've
gone into the sort of popular science
thing when they start sort of like
saying science answers all the questions
philosophy has nothing to say that's it
I think that's really unhelpful way of
looking at it and actually a much more
helpful way of looking at it would be
would be to have some sense of we're all
aiming at trying to understand the world
and we shouldn't assume that that one
particular discipline has a monopoly on
how to do that I mean you get some
philosophers who just think that science
has nothing interesting to say about the
particular issues that they're
interested in and maybe that's true in
some cases but I think a lot of the time
philosophy should be very open to
thinking about the empirical there are
empirical questions that bear on their
topics that they should really be
thinking about so yeah I think a
collaborative approach is the best way
to go because we're all in some sense
trying to understand the world and our
place in it get your tickets for the
world's largest music and philosophy
festival how the light gets in aaaggghhh